more women on company boards MEP s have
voted in favor of quotas to ensure that
women occupy more seats in EU listed
company boards by 2020 forty percent of
non-executive board posts are to be held
by women women have proved to be very
valuable they don't take very risky
decisions they're very responsible and
this will be added value for the economy
it will be added value for the companies
as well men currently heavily out number
one in the boardrooms of Europe's
largest companies women make up just
fifteen percent of non-executive board
members MEP s would like to establish
sanctions for businesses that don't
fulfil the future quota se hace tamam
for the decidi the sanction or efficace
menus aboard own a common example of the
sanction to provide administrative then
dissolution band in our face ooh result
caprice your sheep perv servic river de
force dr. Ella but what has been the
reaction of the business world to this
for this representative of the Belgian
governance and directors Institute it is
the employees competencies which matter
most diversity harmony unique maillot
jaune illimité t consider golden park
sediba de passe Oh Jovie are not
responsible not her preoccupation
premier said oh they are a professional
assassin is administrator the committee
vote in the European Parliament is just
one step in a long legislative journey
MEP s will now have to negotiate with
member state ministers to promote gender
equality in more than five thousand
businesses across the European Union